animals are such a big part of my
sobriety in terms of just like
connecting with you know I mean with
something he does cuddle the animals I
know
you should you should tell I mean
because you had a wonderful
an emu I want to know about the email
tell me about Emos well he loves animals
I I like them what's an emo an emu is
like an ostrich like a giant bird
they're flightless they're flightless
yeah yeah and they're bringing long nuts
yes okay there's seven feet tall their
brains are tiny and they're angry oh I I
like it they're so cute so he we had a
pet emu no yes at your house yes in the
backyard yes when we lived in Malibu and
this is
[Laughter]
have its stomach scratched and it would
come in our house you know and just hang
out with us yeah and not listen nobody
wanted it in the house
but but somehow the dogs were able to
open the doors and then the Emu would
come in oh so they had a relationship
the dogs
wow and how many dogs do you have two uh
now we have three wow great great but at
the time we had an emu we had three dogs
turkeys turkey yeah that would come in
the house yeah so but but this freaking
emu was uh
really and I kept saying you've got to
get rid of this friggin Bird yeah
because I would come home and she would
be uh she'd be in front of the computer
and I'd see over shoulder that she was
looking at a lifespan of emo
seriously I would look it up I would
look it up
yeah yeah wow and one time I was I was
pitching this
um I was pitching a film to this uh
investor from waiting for this call
right yeah and the call came in we had
bad cell reception so I had to go
outside and I'm outside it was hot and I
talking to the guy I'm like here's what
the film is about in this an emu
you never named it by the way I mean it
was Toby Toby so say Toby please respect
Toby yeah
[Laughter]
puppy starts coming at me yeah yeah and
he starts chasing me around the yard and
I'm trying to keep my voice calm yeah
you know because I don't want to tell
this guy yeah I'm sorry I'm being chased
by a Nemo around my yard so I'm like uh
anyway there's a woman who's in this and
bird is coming at me and we go around
the yard and I finally chased him into
the house and closed the doors and
finish the pitch and then Bobby came
home he's like what's going on I go I'll
tell you what's going on
it is that Toby Toby Toby or me oh
ultimatum yeah yeah it got to that point
and he was like listen if you're um if
it means that much to you all you have
to do is say something and I said I've
I've said something to you a lot wow and
I'm done yeah
so he was like he goes well I always
thought it was you know you were kidding
I said no it sounds like I'm kidding
because I'm I'm mad at you about an emu
but it's not a joke anymore yeah so we
found another home eaten by a lion
[Applause]
there was not a long morning period
afterwards
oh I listen it was not on my watch
well hold on stop everyone everyone
restroom
yes holy this reminds me of a time my
dad was really similar with animals I
grew up in the Philippines and one day
he just brought home a monitor lizard
how big is that um pretty big like I
think Komodo dragon but without with a
less infectious mouth and same thing my
mom was like you cannot have that
reptile we have two young children and
he would feed it like chunks of raw meat
and then one day he severed my sister's
paper
just split right in half and she needed
to get it stitched back on okay that's
gonna sit back on they Stitch it back on
but then my dad then donated it to the
zoo and so that's where it went to live
but it didn't get eaten by a mountain
lion like Toby how big yes they get big
yeah Robert are you mad at her I do you
miss Toby let's get there do you miss
Toby I do miss tub
and you think of Toby often right what's
the matter
well I wouldn't allow him into the White
House but I'd keep one in the Rose
Garden yeah there we go there we go
there we go tiger bully fans listen here
you heard her here first Emo's at the
White House emo whatever they're called
emo emo emo is us we're evil don't they
have black hair and they're like cool
sensitive
emotes at the White House guys in a Hot
Topic he's gonna be great
um but one time
she couldn't get in the driveway it
wouldn't let us in the house
every time the every time the gate
opened he would come after us and then
the gate would close and it was just
this ridiculous game and